- Un immeuble à logements
devenu symbole d'apaisement
après une semaine de longs
et difficiles déplacements.
C'est la deuxième fois
en huit ans qu'Elizabeth
fuit la guerre. D'abord, dans
le Donbass en 2014; puis à Kiev,
où elle s'était installée.
Des connaissances l'hébergent
avec sa fille en Roumanie.
C'est dans un simple sac que
tient maintenant leur vie.
Pour venir en aide
aux réfugiés ukrainiens,
les communautés frontalières
se mobilisent. C'est le cas ici,
à Isaccea, en Roumanie,
où ce centre sportif est devenu
un centre d'accueil
pour les Ukrainiens.
Les élèves de cette ville
frontalière viennent donner
un coup de main une fois
les classes terminées.
De l'eau, de la nourriture
et des vêtements :
il y a énormément de denrées
à entreposer. Des ressources
destinées aux réfugiés,
mais aussi du matériel qui sera
acheminé aux Ukrainiens
restés dans leur pays.
À Isaccea, la communauté
est mobilisée, mais après
deux semaines d'efforts
continus, davantage d'appuis
internationaux seraient
appréciés.
"Nous avons besoin d'aide
pour aider", lance cet élu de la
petite municipalité frontalière.
Depuis le début de la guerre,
290 000 réfugiés sont passés
par la Roumanie. Même s'ils sont
nombreux à ne pas rester ici,
la pression est forte pour
cet État, l'un des plus pauvres
de l'Union européenne.
Le Canada assure qu'il épaule
les pays qui sont les premiers
à accueillir les Ukrainiens
qui fuient le conflit.
MÉLANIE JOLY, ministre
des Affaires étrangères
avoir accès à des vêtements,
à de la nourriture parce que
souvent, les gens ont quitté
avec absolument rien dans
les poches. Donc, certainement,
on a offert 150 millions $
aux différentes agences
de l'ONU, à la Croix-Rouge.
- Après quelques jours
en Roumanie, Elizabeth
s'apprête à rejoindre
des proches en Italie.
Elle s'éloigne en conservant
l'espoir de pouvoir un jour
retourner dans son pays,
mais impossible de savoir
quand la tempête passera,
quand la paix reviendra.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, à